- what is this am i hearing an airplane
coming here is it a bird is it a cyber
truck is a Lamborghini so we called them
then the magician here in the office
because we have a joke that he can do
anything and it's not really a joke
because Dan was just like oh yeah I
could probably shoot ok I could probably
fix the Gatsby and we were like ok give
it a try
and then it did well now the door is
broken but guess what then we'll fix it
bad things happen when the Gatsby house
everybody welcome to the h3 podcast Wow
what a joy what a thrill to be here on
this beautiful used what is today
Tuesday Thanksgiving week what a
treasure what a joy so much to look
forward to with our friends and family
and loved ones does everybody hate their
family serious question before we get
into that thank you to hating your
families brought to you by Brooke Lennon
and commanded does everybody hate their
family like does anyone enjoy
Thanksgiving dinner like genuine like
100% with all their heart because I feel
like I hate love it don't ask me what do
you guys think Ben does dan has like
your normal family
yeah I don't hate my family I'm not a
big fan of Thanksgiving know why because
the meat I mean sort of just I'm not a
big fan of Thanksgiving food meat or
broad well I don't that braz Affairs
nothing I know people are gonna call me
on American even Turkey let's be honest
the worst the worst meat I mean it's
just boring yeah I always hated turkey
we're actually we're making brisket this
year and I think I'm going to make the
one exception you are
I don't know I'm on the fence but I
would what an exact do you like
Thanksgiving or do you hate it [ __ ]
hate it
is it the family you hate or the face
different kind of suck I it's the food I
mean this year I'm gonna be with my
girlfriend but we're going to you know
with my family but it just there's
always such a drama always such [ __ ]
the drama the cleaning yeah someone
always doesn't do enough and then the
person that does too much is pissed
terrible and then if you go to someone
else's house the food it really sucks
the turkeys do dry and then you
everyone's a gossiping about how bad the
food was yeah and it's always so awkward
it's like thanks yeah Thanksgiving I say
this Thanksgiving we all order Chinese
food if I'm I thing is if you're
spending time with your family and you
really want to be with them order food
ends your brighter said that is gonna
make broccoli Kish and that is what I'm
excited about I think I might hit that
answer and I think from now on
Thanksgiving should be about broccoli
quiche just says then ADA this is the
Native Americans once cooked Americans
will hate me Ian do you hate being on
the show because you never answer me
every time we switched you people have
commented on it that you always look
miserable no no I like it
thank you like it I like to like it well
I like you too in and I like you being
here but the question of the moment is
do you like Thanksgiving
I mean I'm inclined to like those guys
my family they're cool it's just it's
too close to Christmas it's a little
double-dip and I think yeah like it's
like good
it's like the shitty band opening up for
the act like you're really interested
yes that's cool
but that is kind of what's cool about it
cuz it's like holy they seasoned and
started it's the official people are
taking time off and going places and
doing stuff and buying stuff ft r ez
yeah I mean ft r seems kind of harsh I
mean it's still a band I hate this candy
it's not candy it's a bandy and I don't
understand the analogy I have an
especial exciting announcement Danny's
trying to fix the door let's get a shot
of this I think I [ __ ] it up good man
I actually knocked it off the hinge for
sure it's off the gatsby's unfortunate
this is awesome Emily's about it's not
off the rails Bobby did Bobby took the
whole frame off the wall I just stick
the hinge off come on Dan you got it use
all your strength this podcasters off of
the hinge we're in but we're not getting
out I think I don't think we're getting
out off the hinge thank you perfectly
thank you now guys we haven't had merch
in a long long time it's been a long
time since we've introduced h3 merch
well just in time for the holiday
seasons we have special limited time
only at h3h3 shop calm let me show you
what we've cooked up here today in
spirit of the holidays and spirit of
this beautiful team that we've assembled
here on the on the podcast we have made
a t-shirt to pay homage to each cast
member you can pay homage to each cast
member and and we're splitting the
profits evenly with all of the cast
members this is a elective
this is a going to be a beautiful moment
for everybody we are going five ways on
this so let's see we want to take bets
on which designs gonna sell the best so
let's start with mine now I think mine
is
sell the worse and I'll tell you why
yeah it's like it says Shalom everybody
which is great and I love the dogs in
the apartments for the outfit and then
you've got a feeding window with bagels
interracial if you don't understand
bagel dough burger well from here next
to a Jew it looks like bagels and that's
what I understand but like I don't think
many people are gonna wanna wanna rock
walk around with shirt with like you
know Jewish paraphernalia on it so
unfortunately I kind of agree with you
but I think the design is really funny
if you have the balls to rock at home
everybody then you're gonna look what if
you're Jewish you might want to wear
that to Hanukkah yes maybe you're Jewish
it's a great shirt feel or if you're a
goalie and you just want a four rep your
nation I think it's a great shirt for
you too I'm given I'm not saying you
can't I'm just saying I think there's a
lot of people that would not want to
explain why they're wearing a shalom
everybody shirt but the Hasidic Jew and
dogs with yarmulkes on it now on to
ILA's I'm over it I think this is gonna
be the top seller and this one is just
phenomenal it's got ela I'm over it and
then in the Gatsby really blur its
juming out of frame bro don't really
blur spread each in this shirt is
unbelievable that mobility blur is just
genius
come on and we have to give a shout-out
to our boy Abe he does a lot of our
merch she's a character he's a comedy
genius and he is the pioneer the brain
fine actually this one was done by
should I say who did this Dan or never
why don't you say who did this well a
Abe did the original design and then
there was an overhaul that my girlfriend
actually did thank you know now we've
got Dan the wizard cuz he fixes
everything
honestly and with a with a bag of chips
now originally it was called devil's
advocate and it was me as a little troll
which I liked I just like you know
myself as a little troll with with demon
tusks but this one is is clearly much
better if you could see the old ones you
would understand no apologies to Abe the
concept was beautiful but honestly yeah
we got to go to break it says so dance
is really wearable stanzas are is a is a
really good option
now this one is kawaii as [ __ ] this one
with my Abe Dan the salaried employee
Hawaii
yeah Indian god Danny Valerie employee
white eyes and cheeks I gotta pee so bad
in the cellar employee The Bachelor
everybody loves and Kanye as well who
made that Wow guy named kuba sent it to
us once he upgraded to a salaried
employee we needed a new new vertical
[Music]
beautiful stunning so I think that one
is gonna do very well and now Ian made
this one and I'm like Danny and what am
I paying freelancers for what any Mayo
the Joker is that white paint or Mayo in
her face AK odd I guess it's left for
the imagination I guess no it's up for
interpretation so this one actually is
awesome there they all are right now at
h3 h3 4.com it's perfect for gifts it's
perfect for yourself
it's a perfect stocking stuffer it's a
perfect stocking I don't know anything
about Christmas but if you head on over
to a spacious yeah we're calling them
stalkers
I forgot that they're stalking yes
so there you have it guys the five
holiday shirts only now limited time
only available for two weeks will be in
time for Christmas and everybody gets
paid so now if in I know we only pay him
$1 a month we'll actually have an
opportunity to make a little bit of
money
lord knows that's right so yeah he needs
it badly I've been hearing I need that
second dollar I've been hearing really
hard times for in the salaried employee
so that'll be fun looking forward to
seeing if I'm just being honest I think
it's going to be ela and in are the top
sellers
what do you guys think I I kind of agree
I think you look evil us definitely
that's gonna be number one you know I
think that I hate voting for myself but
I didn't make it I just thought about a
design design with that mobility blurs I
mean and you're awesome everybody would
love CeeLo too so that helps but I think
Dan's gonna be a bit of a dark horse
though I like it honestly is pretty
mainstream at this point
playing I don't like my refer to it mine
is you there can be number two or lost
people just want to rep the nature you
know what I mean the people just want to
support the host the leader the God
really if I'm gonna be humble about it
so I do think that mine will either get
to or last shredder Alfredo with the
little I love that I mean come on I mean
come on right so but we shall see there
you have it
h3h3 shop calm cheese cheese let's see
let's get this out of my face today
mother effers we've got a special
episode mm boy you we got a lot of [ __ ]
from last week's episode people get
angry when I show I can't show videos
but we talk about elective McDonald's
fights mm-hmm so we shouldn't do that
anymore people were really upset
oh so some people say suggest just
putting the links in the description so
long I mean is it or what we still get
in trouble for them no you won't get in
trouble but I just don't think it's a
good idea oh really - link - like no to
talk about something you can't show I
agree I think in general I I I kind of
already had that feeling before we were
gonna do it I thought that they would
enjoy hearing the
the sound of a man battle through a
glass window but it's not his noise yeah
well the more you know what else we had
a lots of other feedback people were
scared I think people are just generally
scared about shoenice yeah we got a
bunch more to come on that but before we
get to that I want to get to the Papa
John pizza reckoning now it's been a
dark time and the Pizza halls of fame
order pizza category Papa we haven't
heard from in a while we tried
desperately to get an interview from
with him I want him on the show he just
did an interview which is making waves
in media and this is just some nobody if
he came on this show we could really
talk about pizza slice by slice you know
what I mean
we could take this we could take this
story slice by slice if I did a
documentary about Papa jonno called
slice one for chapter one mm-hmm very
poetic thank you so there is a lot to
break down here but he is he's coming
hard for these people who took his pizza
throne and the first thing I want to
point out is that he's so wet it's kind
of like I don't wet here he's kind of
like you see like I'm full if a person
could be a pizza right that's how much
of a pizza guy he is he's like I have
become I'm like you know how you're like
sis or bi or whatever he's pizza that's
his orientation they gotta add a P LJ
Thank You P plus P for Papa John pizza P
plus um why is he so wet though for real
he just came fresh out of the oven he
does say in this interview that he's
eaten 40 pizzas in the past 30 days and
I think at a certain point you just
start sweating pizza grease
but let's go ahead and hear from the
Papa God himself I mean this is a
much-anticipated
we've all been waiting breaking the
silence her dream the people that I care
about I love that I've made
multi-millionaires would do what they
did
it was the cart reversal I need to point
out that that is not a Papa John uniform
this guy cannot put away the past he's
where it is it's a closest shirt you
could possibly find to looking like a
Papa John uniform that's not what is
that logo - it's not a fashion brand
it's just unrelated it says Jeff
baseball oh that's that's a yeah you
never heard Jeff baseball no he
literally just found a shirt that looks
like the red work well yeah pop John
this is Jeff baseball I'll stick the
papa of Pizza looking back now do you
think that you were set up
oh there's no question about it and in
the public knows that this do you think
they intentionally had a block due to
interview him because he got outed for
saying the n-word a bunch so they're
probably like let's see what you know
let's put his let's put his pizza to the
in the let's put his feet in the pizza
oven that black guy let me go back
because I don't miss a word set-off oh
there's no question about it
and the public knows that this is I love
that the public knows that yeah it's
such a big a story I love that he thinks
that every public is bawling just pizza
stories no but he used to be a big shot
used to do uh used to be the sole
sponsor the NFL used to do commercials
with like mega celebrity Peyton Manning
is that who I don't know who these
football players are yeah Peyton Manning
I guess he's a big deal this is John
Schneider side of the story and it's
loaded nothing so loaded with olives
it's loaded with that free topping
loaded ism is a pizza reference you say
fully loaded
in the truth sooner or later all comes
out for the first time starter is
talking publicly about the firestorm
that forced him to walk away from the
company on there he built into one of
the nation's largest pizza chains they
made this all up they fabricated it and
shame on them it all started in May of
2018
sinara admits he used the n-word during
what was supposed to be an internal
conference call on diversity training he
used the n-word on a conference call
about diversity training because he got
in trouble for using the n-word because
he got yeah because he caught in trouble
for saying racist stuff right then I
mean I think I'm saying no no it wasn't
he already in trouble before the n-word
thing no I don't think so but I mean it
was diversity training yeah not a good
time to bring up the n-word I don't
think there's a really a good time to
bring up the n-word and take that from
me as someone who said that n-word and
uh it wasn't a good time then either no
stay away from that one folks do you
think Papa John says then where when he
does rap songs in the shower and I'm
thinking probably sister country music
he doesn't if I had to guess Garth
Brooks you think he says the n-word in
country music yeah all races ass country
music I like that but says he did it to
convey his hatred of racism he says in
charters use that as an opportunity to
push him out I just didn't know what
what happened from people on the inside
doing this I thought it would come from
the outside and he's willing to name
names Steve Ritchie and Lilly currently
the board of directors all used the
black community in race as a way to
steal the company and they stole the
company and now they destroyed the
company Steve Ritchie was snotter's
hand-picked replacement but after years
of friendship the two were now is
strangely Olivia curtly is a Papa John's
board member living Carly and Mark
Shapiro should be in jail well that's
that bad what they've done is just
and they've heard a lot of people
Ritchie resigned as CEO earlier this
year but Schneider is still critical of
his former Protege is leadership
everybody knows what that person's make
it everybody knows last year that Steve
Ritchie got six million dollars plus 2.8
million to leave and be quiet and they
got zero bonus they all know that and
sooner or later they you know who wants
to play that game in February understand
what he was missing I think what are you
saying is that all the lower workers are
upset yeah because they brought in a new
CEO and he gets paid like whatever he
just said 8 6.8 million seem like that
much for the CEO of like the biggest
pizza chain but the workers from their
perspective get nothing so I think
that's what he's saying but Papa John
was making more than that and they were
making the same amount of money then I
in one year papa
he's like a millionaire for a CEO to get
paid in one year and that's a lot CEOs
like a lot of big companies that's a lot
I guess that is a lot by golly my
colleague Jeff Smith was named chairman
of the board and Schneider says there's
not a lot of common ground
the one thing he and I agree on is that
Steve rich is not a CEO we that's one
thing we do agree on the new CEO is
former Arby's president Rob Lane oh they
brought in the RB CEO president Oh
president so he wasn't even which he
calls him out for that too it's not even
what are yo material do was gonna happen
to Arby's without their president what's
gonna happen man imagine poaching the
dude from the wolf shittiest food on the
planet earth to come work for your pizza
place or didn't I start putting roast
beef on there he's never been a CEO he
has no pizza experience he's never been
in the pizza category that's a dismal
harpy's that feel like he doesn't have
the passion for quality he's like have
you had Arby's I love that he has never
been the pizza category he hasn't you
can't just go from roast beef sandwiches
to pizza
you got to be in the pizza category for
at least ten years but I have to say in
Shatner's Papajohn Shetty's defense we
have gotten Papa John's since he was
ousted and it's not as good I swear I
got it weak I wasn't even slide wasn't
even cut the pizza sucked it was like a
f tear when Papa John was in office with
Bo in the house that Pizza wouldn't an a
every time sometimes SS careful with SS
controversy that's I mean that's up for
John for Papa John to decide if he's SS
or not I've been watching a lot of
Hitler documentaries on Netflix yeah
it's fascinating I was watching one
about these war criminals who are like
there were so many should I is this a
tangent but it's a plus material here
papa original you know just as an aside
quickly did you know that like of the
two million Nazi war criminals who
exterminated people like only 100 of
them ever went to jail like the Germans
didn't prosecute anybody it's
interesting fascinating one men even say
it's fascinating
okay okay bloomer how dare you say that
to me he doesn't have a passion for
people all changes Chartres says he
hates people
fashion front for people by the way Papa
John Shetty's the one when the health
care reform committee bomb you know is
that I refuse to raise my pizza prices
by two cents to give my voice the health
care coverage yeah talk about a passion
for people though so far he's called him
out on not being CEO material not caring
about quality are being about people
right and not even the pizza category
and being in the pizza category he's
like when you look at him what do you
see a dry face looking at what do you
see greasy wet I'm soaking what that's
what pizza cat I look hot out of the
shower but the last time I shout was a
week ago Blaine that you got a sweater
we don't that's right which spy ring
they've heard people that wake up every
day and make this company great I mean
it's a miserable place over there I mean
they're losing all their good people
this is good people
does anybody specifically told you that
and I love it cause about what they're
miserable I've talked to every
high-level executive that's left it's
like well so many people on the streets
yet exactly and we're talking to half a
dozen executives I mean they've lost
more executives in the last 12 months
than I did in 10 years and after years
of touting better ingredients better
pizza
Snyder says it's ultimately the
customers who are left with the bad
taste in their mouths I've had over 40
pizzas in the last 30 days and it's not
the same pizza Papa Johnny boy here has
this guy's my hero 40 pizzas over 30
days how is that possible
let Mesa go look at him that means ten
days of the last month he had pizza
twice I think he just hate orders Papa
John's you know what I mean mmm
interesting I think he's hate ordering
Papa John's is like okay let's see how
let's order it from this branch and this
branch you think in this very diverse
know that he doesn't work there anymore
yeah I don't know what happens to the
tip no the tips not so big anymore
I wonder if because he was all proud of
the Papa John calm and now it's not even
his Ari tips them big and he's like
joined the movement
I'm gonna cut net you know what I was
thinking I was like dude you're
billionaire just go start another pizza
joint but I was like he can't even use
his own name cuz they own his name dude
today Papa John it's the name of the
company you should start one in the name
of Bo Bo's in the house yeah I'd buy
that I'd buy the effin love and crap out
of that the same product it just doesn't
taste as good the way they're making the
pizza the way they're putting the pizza
together is just not fundamentally sound
to what makes the Papa John's Pizza Papa
John's Pizza it sounds like you're
saying that that it's taking a huge hit
since your departure
would you ever consider or do you want
to go back right now I don't want to go
back but this is still your baby it's
got your name on it your point stuff on
it it's hard to watch this I mean every
single thing you can possibly do wrong
to mismanage this company they're doing
even pick the location because
everything is red
you're on him yeah why would they shoot
in this auditorium whatever it is in
stock and is no longer the largest
individual shareholder my metaphor is
there's no reason to be in the car when
the car crashes even if you love the car
if you were to walk back in there's no
big car crashing though cuz I remember
when we checked the stock it was going
on up when they hired Shaq which by the
way I think Shaq I haven't seen him on a
Papa John it's in a while I mean I've
not heard of Papa John's Pizza since you
left quite frankly Papa John stock price
oh let's look at year-to-date other
there they're doing good actually
oh they're on the rebound but man yeah
Papa I mean sorry to tell you John you
slammed that stock like sure this is the
stock in the last five years this they
were killing it this was Papa John City
then also a Shatner starts dropping the
n-word and diversity training and then
like yeah I'll see you later and then
this is when they hired Shaq everyone
loves Shaq oh but maybe we don't like
Shaq and the pizza stuff but then
suddenly I don't know what happened
Arby's president came to a picture Rob
Lynch is the CEO actually that the big
drop was in 2017 right right here yeah
yeah the the n-word controversy was in
2018 sure he was actually dropping
before that so it's that little I know
that's why they fired him though cuz he
was already blowing it cuz he was there
was a lot of Papa John controversy right
i refresh myself way down
the NFL NFL was Bo he said he didn't
want people in he'll because it was
affecting pizza sales one [ __ ] shut
up idiot
that's broke you want to control what
the NFL does because you're shut up
because he was a big sponsor of the NFL
and he felt like their business was
suffering because of the association
because controversy going on yes yeah
that's when they started to you know
there's a lot of stocks to buy on the
market I just can't imagine investing a
Papa John's to become with they were
doing it's just I don't know you want to
be in the pizza game me I'm not in the
pizza category like owning Jule stock or
some [ __ ] it's like it's the pizza
category you're right okay let's get
back to the NS CEO what do you think the
employees would say if the management
team was out leave and I went back you
know they'd be they be cheering maybe
even backflips they'd be bouncing off
the walls I'm now was up on the street
says he's committed to giving back he
recently made big donations to Simmons a
historically black college and his alma
mater Jeffersonville High School this is
Jeff hi there I started mistake John he
made donations to black colleges and
that's what the shirt is to okay oh but
you know that it looks like that because
he made them change it to look like
puppets on Jersey he bought them on the
observation is that we're gonna change
everything to red yeah I mean Papa John
has weight here too right it's identical
I would just say stay tuned the day of
reckoning will come boom the record will
be straight why not set the record
straight now I mean what is it about the
record a sincerely sorry
stay to the joke costume stay tuned
sooner than later the day of reckoning
is that man maybe it's a boy working on
a new brand he says the more he says the
truth will come out though so it's some
kind of expose did I
never works out whenever people say that
they got nothing Matt Hoss said that
like five years yeah I'll still wait
just wait you know would be epic if Papa
John just murdered a bunch of people and
that's what he was talking about they're
like damn we should have known the day
of reckoning is that an how would Papa
John check out what dance and dominoes
stock yeah it's blown away by how
valuable dominant stock is in comparison
oh wow dude what $300 for share oh they
took a [ __ ] though let's look at that
let's see if there's any correspondence
Oh Domino's is killing it huh well yeah
wow they really since 2016 I was a good
time to buy Domino's seriously holy [ __ ]
and three years their stock value
tripled Domino's is good I got to tell
you I've been getting Domino's huh a
pizza no dominoes dominoes dominoes
pizza [ __ ] and little seizures so there
you go puppies in the house he's making
threats and what can I say that's meme
quality Mikey can you can't do an
interview without shaking the whole
world dude it was all over 3,000 views
and when I woke up this morning is that
six million I think I think in in Papa
John's mind he thinks that people are
just the public cares about his story
and not the fact that he just looks like
a greasy sweat
pizza it doesn't matter
not to Papa just why does the Papa John
come on the show I think there was a
moment when he we were able to maybe get
him no never
when there was somebody that reached out
that said that they can maybe get him on
yeah we yeah be able to say that kind of
stuff oh yeah well I wish it well I just
want the old pee
Papa John Pizza back cuz right now it
sucks it really does suck Pizza has
taken a strong lead in the Pizza wars
and the day reckoning is at hand
just fire bombs Papa John headquarters
kills 300 people blocks all the doors
from the outside we're like wow that's
what he meant
ok fascinating now let's move on let's
talk about you nice we gotta take a
break that was really when we come back
we're gonna close the book on shoenice
we got to decide what are we gonna do
about the shoenice situation how do we
address this what do we think about this
and a special little twist that you guys
are gonna love stay tuned
do not look away the day of reckoning is
coming right after this commercial break
it's that time of year again time to
share smiles and good times with friends
and family and of course to exchange
gifts how about you give yourself a gift
though the gift of self-confidence and
how do you get that by having straighter
brighter teeth with help from candid
candids aligners will help straighten
your teeth faster and cheaper than
traditional wire braces treatments take
just six months on average and cost 65%
glass an experienced orthodontist who is
licensed in your state creates a custom
treatment plan and then they show you a
3d preview so you can see how your teeth
will look after they are done and let me
tell you folks beautiful brighter more
loveable you'll be more loveable I hate
to say it candids aligners are
comfortable removable and completely
invisible I am so jealous of the fact
that people will be able to take it out
when they eat and put it back in
afterwards there's no hassle of going to
North Adonis office candid ships your
aligners directly to you plus in this
season of giving candid donates $25 with
each aligner purchase 2 smile train who
brings safe 100% free cleft lip and
palate treatments to children around the
globe give yourself the gift of candid
go to candid cocom / h3 and use code h3
for $75 off that's CA and D ID co.com /
h3 code h3 for $75 off candid co.com /
h3 coated c let's go
baby do you know the effect of good
linen not just on your body soul and
mine and sleep but when you bring a girl
over this holiday season and you've got
that fireplace going and that rhenium
linen not that target [ __ ] not that crap
that your mom bought you and you were 12
that you still use you know what I'm
talking about
no this is grown-up adult beautiful
linen
that's what Brooklyn is all about Ella
how do you like our Brooklyn and I love
it it feels like a cloud that's it make
your home beautiful is the ultimate form
of self-care and when you sleep you
sleep amazing you spend one third of
your life in sheets don't you want it to
be insanely comfortable Brooke linen
sheets were winner of the best online
bedding category by Good Housekeeping
raving reviews from Business Insider
Apartment Therapy and men's health and
ela Kline 35,000 five-star reviews
more than any other online bedding
company and half a million happy
sleepers Bank County founded in early
2014 by husband and wife Vicky and rich
Fulop who wanted to find beautiful home
essentials that didn't cost an arm and a
leg
their mission to make you comfortable
and to get you laid that I put in that's
not those are my words not theirs
Brooklyn and sheets are the most
comfortable sheets I've slept on and I'm
not just saying that because it's
written down here I actually do believe
that's true and their towels have turned
my bathroom into a spa I don't reckon I
couldn't recommend them more for friends
family or treating yourself to upgrades
you deserve Brooklyn and calm is giving
an exclusive offer just from my
listeners get 10% off and free shipping
when you use the promo code HD at
Brooklyn and calm
Brooklyn is so confident in the product
and there's in the sheets and comforters
and towels that they come with a
lifetime warranty the only way to get
10% off in free shipping is to use a
promo code h3 at Brooklyn and Comm
that's BR oh okay L I and II n comm
promo code h3 Brooklyn these are the
best sheets ever hey guys we're back
people always ask why we running if
we're not live why do we act like we're
live catch my breath because I was
running because we are live technically
we are basically recorded like we're
live so the deal is that we want to we
want to get it all done at once so then
there's no editing so Ian back there is
live switching and clicking and then
when we're done boom it's done and we
upload it and I like the live feel it's
raw it's live it's the same show you we
don't edit it there's no cuts I might
just go off the rails right now but I'll
keep it in we don't cut right Dan right
99% of time we have yeah we should all
the stores we have had to cut yeah what
did we cut before we've cut when when we
knew something was gonna get hit for
copyright okay yeah actually you know
what's great is the reason that we're
actually not doing it live yeah because
people get blocking it not claiming it
blocking it right and we have sponsors
so we can't afford to just not have the
video up so now what we do is we upload
it unlisted and we can see if there's
any claims if there are any claims we
just cut it out and then upload it the
next day you go but it's live baby we
are here run into the bathroom running
out of breath it's all happening
shoenice now a lot of people a lot of
people in space
and why did shoenice flip on you yeah he
was clearly happy to be on the show when
he was here but then after the show it
was all about i trolled h3 ethan is such
a dick
you know I got him I always went and we
were wondering like what his that was
that part was intact but he keeps going
with it and it's looking like I don't
know anymore just doesn't look right
whatever is going on well there was one
really insightful comment actually that
I'll read to you guys that is the most
plausible explanation that I've seen so
here it is this was written by Ken Tama
shoenice possibly has borderline
personality disorder or bipolar again
I'm not here to diagnose the guy but the
rest the rest is what makes sense my
father's very similar with mood swings
shoenice is probably angry that you
touched on some very personal and touchy
issues for him and that it was all a
troll video was his way of trying to
broadcast a sense of control of the
issue to show that he isn't embarrassed
or weak and that he's a winner it's
probably a mindset that he has
subconsciously bought into over the
years in order to stay afloat and keep
his life moving again I've seen the same
behavior from my father who had very
similar life experiences this shoenice
aka broken family drug and alcohol abuse
war trauma and from my perspective he's
angry that you were able to get so close
to his personal demons and feels
humiliated that people are pitying him I
realize just now that I initially wrote
the wrong disorder this is an edit I'm
just committed now though they can share
a lot of similarities depending on the
circumstance well you know what let's
not read the whole edit but I thought
that was an interesting analysis that
he's embarrassed or he doesn't want he's
overcompensating so he doesn't feel weak
or pitied or something so that's his way
to take control of the situation and
it's mine he's like I told you I wasn't
so and furthermore he seems to be
obsessed with the fact that we didn't
even pay him
from a trade straight I'm in a train
station in Denver Colorado and I got you
bro I love that bought me a four loco by
the way there's this crazy channel
called shoenice deleted videos with like
the most dedicated hater of all time
jealous and frustrated shoenice wants
undeserved payout from h3h3 after almost
0 bumps and views I wonder if she oh
nice deleted is sure nice himself if
he'd what if it's oh that was my theory
I think she nights is shoenice deleted
video because who would be this
dedicated yeah and then so he'll posted
on shoenice erase it and then reposted
the shoenice deleted and I wonder if in
his mind he thinks he's getting double
views or something but they're also like
if he is if this is this channel it's
super depressing because look at the
titles shoenice is mad at h3h3 and he's
on the streets pretending he's famous
jealous and frustrated shoenice wants
undeserved payout shoenice drunk
humiliated damage control after HD
podcast embarrassment I don't know the
titles are like super brutal yeah
the whole thing is just kind of I just
don't know his world was going on yeah
shoenice humiliation damage control part
1 sure nice is pissed that h straights
tree exposed and humiliated him I don't
think we humiliated him that's the bad
thing no we didn't humiliate him I
thought we all had a good time
yeah and so I feel like only in his mind
he would he see it that way I don't
think there's anyone that cares enough
to do this except him I feel that this
has to be shoenice
but be that as it may he's clearly upset
that we didn't pay him first time we
don't pay any of our guests but we
wanted to find a way to compensate him
we wanted to find a way to bury the
hatchet and so what we did is we went
over to shoenice his cameo and we
purchased everybody here in the office a
cameo from shoenice to celebrate this
holiday season Danny and Zach ela and
myself all got a special shoenice cameo
so guys if you want your own shoenice
cameo you know where to go it's cameo
dot scott ever [ __ ] cameo but shouts
assurance so Dan this is for you so
listen boy yeah enjoy hey Daniel knows
everything about editing yeah Logan Paul
tried to comp him and look at his
podcast a joke were you gonna do either
way thanks for buying me Danny's guys
tink ya know each cameo cost 10 bucks so
we gave him 50 bucks essentially
although I wonder what cameos cut is a
good point like 25% or something
probably yeah might be less I was he he
got real nice in the cameras I was
expecting more [ __ ] talk he just [ __ ]
talks Logan Paul and like every cameo
for some reason there's one for Ian in
happy Holidays to you from show night
hey everyone shoenice again well
basically this is a shout out to intern
Ian the dude is no joke but you better
listen to Daniel he will bust your ass
like you give us Jake Paul's ass there
from whatever that thing was called yeah
yeah but he really put a lot of effort
in today's I'm happy to see Zach happy
holidays from shoenice and um listen up
this one's for you Zach
everyone shoenice again well basically
this is a shout-out to Zack one of the
greatest producers anywhere known on any
podcast
Wow that I can pull he's nuts yeah yeah
there you have it your cameo turned
quickly into an insult to Logan Paul I'm
honored you should be yellow this is
once for you I got worried about this
one because you kept making really weird
sexual comments about ela but I think he
kept it clean for you though
hey everyone shoenice again well
basically this cameo is just a shout out
my really good friend Neil a really good
writer way that prettiest girl on
YouTube makes jenna Marbles look like a
poodle either by doing what oh wait I
got me killed
yeah he what's it almost got me killed
him Oh probably because he was saying
rude [ __ ] wrong everyone almost killed
him I don't know but I find that he has
a hard time complimenting somebody
without insulting somebody I know it's
like you're the best and this person is
worse compared to you so Jenna Marbles
I'm not sure what she did to incur the
wrath of the shoe and me I was most
nervous of all for this one I was
expecting like ethan klein this is your
address I'll see you tonight at 10:00
8:00 p.m. no but he
hey everyone shoenice again well
basically I just want to shout out my
boy Ethan good boy Jake Paul and his
brother here's the song here oh yeah all
right
I wouldn't I'd be lying I think it's
time to put the shoe in the box to pay
less by the way um
um it's so funny on cameo oh dude he's
got a [ __ ] ass load he sold 500
review that's a lot this guy's active
four point nine stars to the man love
Shoei
um the weird thing about cameo is that
every cameo they make is public you can
watch them on his neck so
determined dog shoe yes in a way it's
good to keep people from getting weird
on the platform actually that's all very
transparent it's right there it's
actually up to the person ordering
whether or not you want it to be no
because they're they're celebrities I
mean and if they do show their dick then
you get what you paid for
I'm just not sure if that's what can you
know why show me his dick for 10 bucks
maybe for 20 I don't do I have the
option of paying more damn I didn't see
I didn't see a way yeah it's just an
extent there's no negotiating I'll say
show me your dick or buy another one
he's actually making a lot of money from
this let's see what this who's this guy
YouTube star Cameron Karl let's see what
he has to say to his fans I love this
[ __ ] dude can you start closer to your
face what is this if you want to shout
for your birthday Christmas whatever but
you know speaking of so that's it we're
as ela said this time to put the shoe
back in the box
are we getting a refund are we just
putting at Natick i just storage some
did you save the receipt no are you
donating it to Goodwill are you keeping
it I just put it in a storage unit
sword unit that means it'll probably go
in the garbage in a couple of years but
you're not ready just yet yeah yeah what
kind of shoes are they like like Nikes
adidas it's like used up Reebok not good
yeah Reebok used lots of mileage lot of
mileage yeah speaking of cameo one of my
favorite stories of the decade came out
of cameo you remember mark McGrath from
Sugar Ray popular band when I was a kid
bad app I'm bumper how's it going
every morning's and combated embedded it
that you know that song
I just got claimed because I was so
pretty perfect every morning as ransom
bad medicine bit you guys know what I'm
singing right touch no a baby don't say
a word
every morning shut the door baby don't
say a word
Sugar Ray every girl wanted to all the
guys wanted to be him and all the girls
wanted to [ __ ] and now he now he all
a lot of these handsome guys I'm I found
you know they say the trope is that men
age more gracefully than women and I and
I and I would say that you know I see
the blood they mean by that but a lot of
these pretty boys try so desperately to
hold on to their looks and they don't
they refuse to age gracefully and I
think now they don't embrace the aging
yes and they still try to look like when
they were eggs back then rule bro he's
like 50 and he still got frosted tips
like that that's doesn't work anymore
I'm Frost the tips you know what I'm
saying but so mark McGrath is on cameo
for $100 by the way his net worth is
estimated at like 8 million mm-hmm why
the [ __ ] would you do a cameo for a
hundred bucks
but wait see you watch I don't know
everyone is on carrion so it's so easy
just do it in your spare time dude
seeing it's it's public it's like dog
you're not okay I don't know it's good
for some people but it's like your mind
come on Sugar Ray it's kind of great for
a lot of people like tuna you know
consider doing cameo Danny and Zac it's
great for you guys you guys world make
some money on that and you see so just a
minute ago you said I wouldn't do it but
they should do it I just think it's not
it's not for you without you know cameo
man I want to see you guys on cameo I'll
do it back you could play little tunes
for people 25 bucks
Ian would you do it I'm cool thank you
Wow okay - good exactly what is that
would you eat like a spoonful of mayo
for 25 no that happy birthday anyway
mark McGrath accepted a cameo request
for a hundred dollars a girlfriend
wanted to break up with her boyfriend
via mark McGrath his favorite band so
imagine getting this cameo from your
favorite artist saying that your
girlfriend wants to break up with you I
mean you got to see this it's like it's
amazing it is mark McGrath from the band
sugar ray off the charts but always in
your hearts is oh by the way all of his
cameos he says off the charts but always
in your heart hey thanks bro he's like
branding himself are they off the charts
I mean I don't think they've been on
they are off the charts oh is that but
in your heart okay so he's yeah I
thought he was saying like off the chart
no off the chart okay so I approve that
I like it what do you think about the
hair you look and I feel like I'm
watching a fear factor you know it's
like oh look like timepiece a timepiece
fun so let's watch this cameo was booked
by Cheyenne and she wants you to know a
few things because it's the first one of
these I've done but she wants you to
know that you mean a lot to her you mean
the world to her but she's having
difficulty staying in this long-distance
relationship I'm you know it's tough
I've been on the road for years and I've
been with my wife a long time and the
biggest arguments the biggest you know
obstacles in our relationships is the
distance between us it makes it very
difficult when around the road
and it's hard so Cheyenne is trying to
let you know brain that it's very very
tough for her to stay in this
relationship she still cares about you a
lot
you never know what the future may hold
and she still wants to be friends with
you because obviously she cares did she
give him all that information he must
but I think he is improvising like you
don't know yeah there's not an ounce of
humor in this
that's what's striking to me is that he
sees himself as a legitimate mediator
here and it keeps going man he just he
keeps going but I understand you know
you gotta work on your thesis and life
goes on and you know I'm sure there's
big things ahead of you in the future
Braden but Cheyenne cares about you got
a great day let you know I wonder if
he's gonna get a slew of breakup video
requests now I kind of want to get one
for you for April Fool's video from a
divorce
[ __ ] breakup a divorce video from mark
McGrath hey Ethan
so ela wanted to tell you that she has
given me the papers yeah and I do have a
black pen here for you you just need to
sign this the papers are in your
nightstand eva has moved out already
here's the address it's already pre and
look is this maybe a little hard but
you'll get over it
you know maybe she'll come back you
don't know there's the slight issue she
did run off with shoenice I'd be worried
mark McGrath told me you ran off with
shoenice I'll be like mark McGrath and
shoe Knights have deducted my wife and
she wants you to stay positive
they pogchamp is my law knows that
you're a fan of the band Sugar Ray which
I'm honored I wish I was delivering you
good news hopefully I can see you back
good enough fake
hello you're a fan of Howard Stern I'll
ask Howard to the poor's bro you could
have said no it's just a hundred bucks
just say no it's a weird request
sometimes you have to do the
long-distance things a little difficult
but she wishes you nothing but the best
all the love in the world and do do do
do your best on that thesis man I know
it's a it's tough in the holiday season
is trying to correlation ships and all
that stuff man but you got big things
that how do you bro if you're working on
a thesis you've got a good life in front
of you I've worked on me and I'm no
puppy student be positive bro all right
be positive bro all right well she
definitely got our minds worth what are
you guys are thoughts on that
unbelievable
this is cameo and taking on a new level
that's not yeah if that's not what cameo
was made for him know what it was I got
delivering bad news to a cameo sorry to
tell you this we just got word that your
mother has passed away it was a quick
but I did hear that you're a fan of me
so you're a fan of me so we thought that
would soften the blow so I'm honored
that your fan but yes this your mother
is dead so would they already had the
funeral they didn't want to tell you you
know and it is your fault that that
Mexican food you made for her was too
spicy and she blew out her colon so she
apparently broke up because of their
long distance the kind of sounds like an
excuse yeah of course it's an excuse you
got mark McGrath so someone's phone oh
yes phone is not muted I swear to god
it's on do not disturb you no it's not
when I because we just heard it podcast
my phone started ringing - and smellin
do not disturb
we always then always says everyone put
your phone on mute you didn't always
says yes it's muted every morning
there's a matter thinka matter that that
butter that da da da oh I was looking to
mark McGrath's he even plays music for
people for a hundred bucks he does like
private shows it's crazy man that guy
hustles let me look at mark McGrath's um
and how long are those videos dude
they're all super long yeah but I mean
super long for a cameo but under two
minutes right are you defending the
hundred bucks for two minutes or work
good I guess I know but he's like what
you keep saying that he's got a net
worth is six million but how much income
does he have in 20 years residuals from
mark McRae he's got a lot of work now
he's also gonna like TV like extra or
something like that like daytime TV a
judge on some real good smart from the
band sugar a off the charts but always
in your hearts and I understand from
your friend Lisa that it was just your
one at year and I wanted to play I mean
what is under bursaries congratulations
one year it's not damn it they don't let
me play it all at once
hey Christian what's up my brother it's
mark McGrath from the band sugar ray off
the charts from the cars in your hearts
and I just want to say a very happy
birthday today you're turning 40 well
done my friend the 40's a good day
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hitting all those buttons cause their
feet didn't walk out so I gotta turn
everything off too much epicness to it
for a mark McGrath's earring every
Sunday it is embackment bow of his hair
really because I was I had like hair
insecurity because I have curly hair and
I was always so jealous cuz back when I
was a kid it was all about straight yeah
out frosted tips spiky hair and no I was
so insecure about my hair mark McGrath
young you're gonna you're gonna want to
[ __ ] young mark McGrath tell me that you
don't want to [ __ ] young mark McGrath he
kind of looks like a dish come on you
don't want to [ __ ] young mark McGrath I
like it
just me you don't wanna [ __ ] young mark
McGrath the holy war on gays oh [ __ ]
that's what it says I'm the magazine
covered that he's on I don't know I mean
yes yeah I think that is style today it
just really doesn't he had he didn't he
never switched the style yeah this was
cool in the 90s or whenever he was Oh
to see now he's now he's what do you
think about that it his nips are really
like showing with a lot of tattoos
you know they got successful on a fluke
it was a fluke song what does that mean
so like when they they were originally a
punk band and they came out with this
song fly which is like I just wanna fly
that's where that's omputer
oh is that like a goof
song in the exactly was Jenny became the
goof exactly he got lost in the thaw
exactly so that's why they made that
like reggae type either do you like the
frosted tips and goatee look or not I
hate the girl thing the goatee was such
a thing that's my problem such an
awesome look back then yeah
what is this put your shirt down look at
this picture of Ashton Kutcher why
doesn't let me scroll up man I like it
I can't you guys it doesn't let me go up
all right I'm out I don't know look at
Ashton Kutcher just with this shirt up
like who'd you rather [ __ ] mark McGrath
or Ashton Kutcher go ahead is it not
obvious no I don't know I think rooster
oh you write it stir hmm no insane I
won't fly I think that's kind of like
unquestionable no he's um he was a model
yeah yeah but he's also wasn't what what
did he do something like that okay just
looks like I did with the goatee yeah
hmm don't know insecure since you said
you want to [ __ ] oh sure I don't mind if
I can do one just being on let's get off
this well Don asked me this question
King no I'm glad you answered honestly
it was interesting Jesus we'd rather
[ __ ] astronaut you're too nice honestly
let's not use the f-word
no I'm kidding I'm not insecure I'm just
deeply disappointed cuz you're secretly
into um mark mark I want to I want to I
was jealous of his hair because back
then in middle school second if I only
had frosted tips and short hair I would
have a girlfriend right now
and the reason that I'm not don't have a
girlfriend cuz I have curly hair only
yeah but today who's got the better hair
you there you go
[ __ ] you mark [ __ ] ass on cameo loser I
should make him say like you've got the
best hair mark McGrath congratulations
on having awesome hair you cannot be
super jealous now you know well that was
fun if you guys by the way come up on
any other crazy cameos I want them I
live for these candies I want to just
inject it into my veins I love crazy
wacky crazy
that is what else we got Star Wars okay
Mandalorian amazing I love the
Mandalorian it feels like Star Wars it
feels like Star Wars everything about it
it's gritty it's awesome
it's not overly campy as perfectly can't
be it's fun it's exciting it's got baby
Yoda I would literally I think I would
kill my cousin for baby Yoda a cousin I
would kill a cousin I was I was going
down the list of family members like mom
no dad like well no not really
he is my dad after all and then I was a
cousin yeah I'd killed cousin I probably
kill all of them for baby Yoda what is
the what's the scenario why would you if
someone was like you hat you here's a
gun you have to kill one or the other
hmm I would kill my cousin for sure I
would probably kill my whole extended
family you're gonna buy that baby you'd
emerge chain but the reason that I'm
talking about how great the Mandalorian
is is because the new the final Star
Wars of the new trilogy the rise of
Skywalker came out and I have to say I
don't [ __ ] care about this stupid-ass
trilogy these movies
the mandalorian as far as I'm aware is
the new Star Wars like watch how stupid
the [ __ ] is and I'm so over these movies
watch y'all dumbasses they release this
being like oh this is awesome this is a
hyper click first of all this feels like
a generic action movie no that's all it
is and you'll see the dialogue just
makes me want to die
[Music]
why would it do that like that the new
make sense
I hate that I hate that it's awful it's
horrible it's not funny I hit all those
characters and by the way the guy who's
driving the thing who's like they fly
now and the first one he was fine and
the second one he was so obnoxious
so unlikable I hate that character I
hate everybody there I hate the [ __ ]
even local actors know the character
yeah the actor I've no beef with ya you
know in the mandalorian it's all perfect
amazing uncontrived well great pace
episode and thrilling story it's so good
I like it I like it I like it I like it
I like I like I like I like it I like it
I like it I like it I like it I I'm over
it I'm over it I like it I'm over it
I like I'm over it I like a kiss
cheers cheers Cheers
I like it I'm over it I like it I'm over
it
Cheers fascinating over years doesn't
this look so awful it's so I I saw it
and I immediately erased it from my
memory I'm so glad that they made the
mandalorian and I'm so glad they gave it
to John far for it's his name Avril
Favreau because this is a Talent this is
a guy who lives in British Star Wars and
comic books and fantasy this is a guy
who who cares about the craft and the
Star Wars universe he honors the Star
Wars that people know and love this is a
bastardization this should never have
been made the Mandalorian is the real
Star Wars I love it I approve this is
trash I hate everything about it they
fly now and we still haven't seen the
bill bar cameo
oh yeah bill burr Mandalorian I'm
waiting for that enemy of the show you
know you say friends of the show bill
burrs enemy of the show I'm
kidding of course no Neela's like mmm
enemy at the show that's a very American
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to know why they're I mean I
guess maybe I'll make sense in the movie
but as for [ __ ] stormtroopers why are
they running away from four
stormtroopers I know those guys can't
shoot for [ __ ] and raise a [ __ ] Jedi
No
right just own them just take out your
lightsaber and murder them there's
probably more back there do some 11 who
cares the movie sucks they are awful I
mean the last Star Wars was joy look at
trailers this is awful
there's just a teaser it's not really a
trailer I like a Z I hate it I'm over it
I like it too slow Zack so um you guys
all been watching Mandalorian right
yup I'm caught up love it hate it think
it's okay
I'm still liking it then are you
starving it's true are you just eating I
heard you live up to the man man are you
starving I'm hungry it's true we
starting late again he's always eating
chips back here yeah it's it's authentic
what flavor you got these spicy queso
they're gonna say are a little it's a
little disappointing the jalapeno ones
we're good
I'm getting a while before your heart I
know I'd me too meeting way too many of
these chips that's right you're healthy
boy you're vegetarian you know what it
is it's like with the I quit the no
that's true appetite suppressant well
that's got to be better for you than
that slamming chips and I think maybe
it's true might be a net neutral we're
all very proud of you by the way good in
banking that's great news
don't go and die on me I mean I need you
died like from a heart attack from
eating or what I mean ships no from
vaping oh oh don't go get a double lung
transplant that happened to some poor
bastard who was vaping you had to get a
double lung
transplant no I think I think it's been
pretty much confirmed now that it was it
was all down to the THC stuff not the
not the drool pods by year but don't lie
you've been you were spooked to smoke
that [ __ ] a little bit but I also just
wanted to quit so it was it was sort of
like the last little push yeah it was a
good reason to finally do it I mean I
started doing month right it's been
longer than yeah dan stop when we was
already running at that point I think
that was the last day that I completely
cool Star Wars oh this is a this is such
an awesome story I'm not even - you know
incredible it's amazing it's like
entertaining it's got twists it's got
turns this is something that you think
only happens in movies but the biggest
jewelry heist in history took place
recently and traced in Museum it's
estimated that the thieves grabbed a
billion euros a billion euros worth of
jewels that's insane
it's like the biggest heist by far of
all time it's so incredible I've got
these visual aids here here's an amateur
album as I as I so here's the case that
they this was like the biggest
collection of medieval jewelry owned by
kings and all this in Europe and you
could see that wasn't necessarily
medieval was more like 18th century yeah
honestly oh this this by the way look at
this one million dollar coin whoa isn't
that awesome
they stole that [ __ ] by so look at this
diamond
oh look at this [ __ ] okay nice whoa
that's a surah but what can you doing it
now oh so I'll get to that and this is
like some huge teardrop diamond pen oh
my god so they stole all this [ __ ] and
so much more a billion dollars let me
read you that the facts of this here
there's a video of it um let me play the
video cuz there's no sound and I'll read
you the the facts jack so here they are
the details of this heist is amazing and
my favorite the green vault my favorite
part of this heist is that they were
reportedly extraordinarily tiny people
right because there was just a hole they
pried open in the bars was the size of a
head huh so they they you know like in
these heist movies they go and get like
some Vietnamese from Jesus it really uh
some hot little twink oh yeah they
literally did that in Ocean's eleven
yeah they got they got a little
Vietnamese like trapeze twink really
yeah suitcase yeah and so they they
literally did that that's all that
should do so so let me read you the
details thieves in German city of
Dresden have broken into one of Europe's
largest collections of art treasures
making off with three sets of
eighteenth-century jewelry of
immeasurable worth and what Germany has
described as the biggest such theft of
all time the popular German daily build
says the thieves grabbed jewels worth 1
billion euros the dramatic heist took
place on Monday after a fire broke
here's where it gets crazy
a fire broke out and an electrical
disturbance deactivated the museum's
alarms and plunged the area into
darkness German media described the
strikingly small thieves who managed to
get through a tiny hole to enter the
vault as leaving behind bulky objects
such as vases and pain
mmm-hmm the correspondent for german
broadcast described the whole the
thieves got through as being no larger
than my head that's crazy
the thieve the break-in only lasted a
few minutes the emergency call was made
at 5:59 a.m. the police arrived at 5:05
a.m. six minutes afterwards but may 6
six minutes later five four five I
understand that I said it wrong 559 a.m.
and the police arrived at 5:05 a.m. they
say that right no you didn't know how do
5:05 know four one nine five Oh what did
I say 59 ok 459 they arrived at 505 6
minutes ok now it makes the police
arrived a mere 6 minutes after the
emergency called but the thieves had
already fled the scene Wow investigators
ago for oh so the investigators linked
the same gang stole a estimated 4.5
million dollar coin from the Museum of
Berlin in 2011 that was third item 17
did this and the heist the burglars used
a ladder to steal the huge gold coin
featuring the bust of Queen Elizabeth
the second that's when I showed you I
think on the front from the bode museum
according to the build up to a billion
euros worth of treasure was stolen I
already said that extras of the museum
who once boasted that the collection was
a secure as Fort Knox said today that
the items stolen were of immeasurable
wealth and pleaded for the thieves not
to destroy them so get there because the
pieces are so famous there's no way that
they could sell those yeah what market
listen to this manager for the art
auction house told the tabloids that if
the objects stolen had a value of a
billion euros as initially estimated by
the police even if they were broken down
and melted to the raw materials they
would still be worth a hundred to two
hundred million
which makes it well worth stealing them
isn't that just the raw materials the
building was being patrolled by two
guards in the center of the building
according to German media the first
officer arrived on the scene within
minutes but that these have already fled
in a get a getaway car that was waiting
outside which managed to elude immediate
attempts to find it in the surrounding
area and on nearby highways the police
told reporters police later confirmed
that a out e86 matching the description
of the getaway car was found burned in
an underway parking lot and raised him
isn't that insane they blew the fuse
they somehow put the fire out a fire and
put the power out had this getaway car
they sell fire so really like oceans
dude they got in six minutes they
disappeared they had the whole city
locked down and these guys had this
crazy getaway route and they were unable
to find them a billion dollars the
outter so the plater can free
yada-yada-yada investors the
investigators suspect that the fire and
of an electrical junction box near the
museum which took out the street lights
at the time of the robbery was linked to
the crime the outage affected lights in
front of the window which they gained
entrance and somehow getting through
bars and safety glass to reach the jewel
room police said they have established a
special investigating team comprising 20
specialist officers to solve the case my
only question is this when does the
movie come out I wonder even if they
wanted to just sell the materials if
they would still get caught because the
material sound really rare here's what I
would really miss if ik and I'm sure
they're much smaller smarter than I am
melts it all down to the base materials
and then sell them all over the place
you know they like a really raw diamond
or really unique shaped diamond I think
I saw another article where they they
guessed that the diamonds would probably
they would recut them you can just read
sad ham that is sad yeah I mean these
are precious that it
is sad that they are but at the same
time I'm kind of stoked for them isn't
that sick they got these little
Vietnamese twinks to crawl between the
bars I mean I hate that they're gonna
ruin this crazy jewelry what historic
but I am kind of stoked for them I like
to watch it as a movie but I don't like
it in reality because you know in the
movie they'd be like cool and
charismatic you know in them rooting for
me and Brad Pitt and Leonardo DiCaprio
you know yeah directed it sucks yeah in
reality they probably like [ __ ]
killed people there are some like super
rich people that would buy this stuff
like to put in their own collection I
don't think you I think it was a way too
risky to buy the the actual the actual
piece I mean if there's a serious
investigation if I'm assuming they would
be looking but yeah I think they're
gonna melt that it's worth 200 million
bucks mm-hmm damn now that's a payday
though it's just crazy that this stuff
actually happens yeah hmm it's amazing
I'm just thinking about these little
twinks and uh I wonder if they had Paul
McGrath or Paul McGrath mark McGrath's
hair and I'm just wondering would you
want to [ __ ] a little Vietnamese twink
with Paul McGrath or mark McGrath's
airhole nah no baby no for deer hunting
season is open in Wisconsin you'll be
happy to know yellow and in the opening
weekend alone four people were shot
thank you
keep shooting each other isn't that
amazing I think more people got shot
than deer at least four people were shot
in Wisconsin during the state's
opening weekend of deer hunting one a 38
year old man was hunting and needy yeah
I hate pronouncing like when I see some
a word for the first time I've got like
oxd I get like existential dread because
I know I can't read it
oh and eid aight how do you pronounce
that i don't know what would you use for
what when you get eggs existential oh
are you
one expecting angst okay fine it's like
some egyptian does it use or something
no it's not almost that I get in it I
get existential office every time I
heard and correct me uh twenty eight
year old man was shot in the foot
what did you send me dead a donk okay
[Music]
what is this some stupid Star Wars [ __ ]
get off my screen oh my god I can't
close it Dan I'm having lost I can't
close it
why what is this [ __ ] okay no I good
doesn't work I mean what the [ __ ] I'm
not watching your [ __ ] you know I might
skip that movie I might just straight-up
skip it
I'm serious [ __ ] Star Wars
I'm Mandalorian all the way at 38 year
old man was shot in the foot the same
thing happened 29 year old woman I shot
a hunter shot at a running deer and
struck a 19 year old woman the left hand
another man can you imagine you're like
oh hi mom
whoops oh hi mark another man was shot
while deer hunting the Wisconsin
Department of Natural Resources asking
for the public's help in the case which
is still under investigation
more people got shot than deers oh
that's my nose a joke I wrote myself
they should rename it human season I
wrote what I wrote more people got shot
in deers they should rename it humans
season they
Shanee season who famously shot his
friend in the face during deer season
did you know that yellow eye the
vice-president his homie in the face it
was duck hunting Oh duck hunting excuse
me
and then and then Dick Cheney made back
I apologized to him for a while eh yeah
for standing in the way yeah for causing
him grievance Andy Dick Cheney Dick
Cheney sued him I don't think I know I
don't think he sued him Dick Cheney said
apologize I'll finish the job
Wow but what happens if you shoot
someone is that not a crime can you just
go murder vice president dude but now
seriously if you're deer hunting can you
just go shoot people it's like all good
it's like whoops
I mean if it's an act like you're
already Monday field no one cares about
you who's to say accident from attempted
murder Dan oops
you know I'm saying yeah and that's that
what that's what I tell the judge you
have a good point thank you but let's
put that aside and let's just enjoy this
story because I think it's great I agree
I don't like people don't mind like when
someone dies at the hands of like a or
like a tiger or elephant I'm like dude
you're [ __ ] dead bro you got owned
it's so outrageous that these hunters
think like they Trump the Trump boys who
go out there and kill [ __ ] elephants
you know it's done yeah the Trump's boys
should there is a distinction between
hunting deer and and big game on yeah
there is a little different I agree
because they're I guess they either that
deers are in some areas too there's too
much and the population needs to be cold
yes we we made all the Predators extinct
so now that deer population is like
running away so got to get rid of them
like that but it's just so outrageous to
go kill a [ __ ] elephant
to fly to Africa thing with Ellen Ellen
what said I'm definitely with you on
that yeah you know there's all this
propaganda better to like oh go seconf a
shin do these come these countries are
so corrupt you think it really makes it
they just just one goes to concert they
say they always say dude I go hey I'm a
the government to get a license to kill
an elephant and all that money goes to
conserving so it's a good thing that I'm
going to Africa and killing ones yeah
they that's I always hear that in
defense of these big game hunters who by
the way are giant [ __ ] they go sneak
up on elephants in enclosed environment
they have a basically a ranger who knows
how to crack them they just follow some
local and then they go okay theory
eschew it's like you're a [ __ ] who
cares that you shot the Elven you didn't
do anything all you did was pull the
trigger bro if you want to go kill an
elephant and be a man go out to the saw
go out there by yourself and hunt some
big game otherwise you're a [ __ ] I'm
gonna pull up these pictures of the
dumbass Trump by the way Trump's kids I
mean no offense I know people like them
but they're the biggest [ __ ] goons on
the let me just look at him you know
what I'm saying Eric and what's the
other ones Donald don't Don jr. I mean
look you may like Trump as a president
and as a guy but you have to admit that
his sons are the biggest [ __ ] goons
look at these boat look at that bro look
at these two idiots look at these guys
why do you look like a dude he looks
like the woods sloth he literally looks
like sloth he looks like The Hunchback
of Notre dance all right this is on
Snopes
we should roll down that's true balls
so where's the real one I doubt it's
much better oh yeah look at his hair
look at these go and by the way Trump
has a fat daughter
that nobody knows he has a daughter cuz
he hates her because she's fat I swear
to God he has an extra daughter you
thought it was just the three them right
yeah but there's another no and there's
the little boy
no but there's a secret daughter that's
fat I swear to God Donald Trump secret
dog my name is Tiffany oh you see
Tiffany yeah it's not a secret but no
really ever heard a Tiffany Trump I mean
I've heard of her yeah you're right that
she's it's not in the public eye when
have you ever seen her ela never exactly
he doesn't like her cuz she's fat I
heard that and she's not pretty that's
what he says he doesn't like this
daughter when have you ever seen her I'm
dead serious
I don't know maybe she doesn't want to
be no dude I'm telling you he doesn't
like fat people and he definitely
doesn't like women at least unless
they're you know he had himself done he
wants to grab does he hate himself
cuz he's bad because I guess it's
thicker than a snicker don't you think
that the kids are just the biggest goons
ever I don't like this I want to go back
to the hunting well okay so the point
that I brought up these goons is a trump
sons big our songs sons big-game hunting
so I wanted to show you this here they
are with a leopard yeah look at these uh
hotshots wow they probably tracked that
down by themselves why would you want to
do that look at this beautiful animal a
lot more beautiful than these goons
that's so sad it's it's it's horrific I
mean here here's a look at him with a
nut bro really deeply wrong with you
come on don't do that it's you wanna
kill [ __ ] but killing humans is illegal
look just just posing with a dead
carcass that's your idea of a fun time
with this beautiful majestic creature by
the way a leopard these are rare these
are not look at that beautiful creature
No and look at this hideous monster of a
man I'm not down with that I don't care
what the [ __ ] anyone says I don't care
about yeah I don't care if they gave a
million dollars in Bob way for just a
million dollars there yeah you care
about conservation a million dollars up
guy if these guys were crawling around
the desert floor like a predator with
mud on their eyes and smelling like
feces maybe I'd have a little respect
for the big game hunt that's not what's
going on here
no they're being carried in their van by
some local eating eating even like that
the whole setup is being set up for them
and then they're like okay here it is
shoot there he is okay here's the gun
now they probably put his finger on his
finger to pull it you did it
oh you're so great so brave you sent me
something Zach would you send me oh yeah
I mean it the fake one definitely looked
the fake one definitely looked like that
the real one was yeah agreed so I don't
like big-game hunters I don't like this
[ __ ] either by the way you know
that's the guy that killed that wine the
dentist they got all the [ __ ] okay here
oh look at this big game hunter oh my
god that [ __ ] who probably
weighs more than the lion itself
nobody likes a good feed bro look at
that creature not he not him look at
that beautiful lion let me tell you this
picture is everything that's wrong with
with humanity and correctly look at that
majestic beautiful lion this is a
magical creature just let it be why do
you need to go kill a line you fat [ __ ]
bro did you did you were you literally
going through the desert in a wheelchair
and like a in a mobility scooter yeah an
off-road guy oh that tank one yeah I
hate these people
I really do I think they're absolute low
life scum bags
sickos Psychopaths mm-hmm look at this
one
get it bro when you when these guys die
and go to hell I hope this images of
like on all walls other held prison dude
this guy just killed a bunch of monkeys
like my god eriously dude what is wrong
with you so yeah I'm happy when these
people die I am actually happy I have
blood lust for root for the animals
every time dude homie was just taking
out monkeys with a crossbow go play a
video game a video what a crossbow think
what else what else what else I hate
these people I'm a vegetarian now say
you can't even say [ __ ] about me I saved
the world [ __ ] am i doing am i
being hypocritical cause I've eaten meat
my whole life a little bit sure
but at the same time I think they're
raised there is a there's a difference
in that the cattle is raised for
consumption
these are majestic wild endangered
species and I agree that that that you
know it's probably unethical to eat meat
though because of the way they're raised
do I care then I'm being hypocritical
well I'm a vegetarian now which means
I'm a saint and I could say what the
[ __ ] I want Dan do you agree and
disagree we got on this whole topic
because we were talking about the deer
hunting those are the people that got
shot the deer hunters are fine if it's
if it's part of ecologic if it's part of
you know maintaining a healthy ecology
is it always like that in America it is
I think in Wisconsin which is where the
story took place likely yes there's a
lot of basis of know there's a lot of
places that they because all of the
Wolves got run to extinction and the
wolves were what kept the deer
population in check so now the deer are
the out of control and mm-hmm they have
to call the herd basically call the herd
but you eat deer by the way you don't
eat lion yeah I'm completely with you
yeah [ __ ] the people there is literally
no making a distinction between the two
types of I agree there's there's no
purpose to killing a lion other than
that you want to murder something
beautiful
pretty much yet a deer you can eat you
can eat people love venison when you're
helping the environment thoughts I'm
over it
we're deep in the episodes because
should talk [ __ ] about Trump more no raw
is a big fat burger eating [ __ ] he is
gotta buy an ass in and what he's
literally wears a diaper Donald Trump
wears a diaper
I swear to God look at picture of him
playing tennis I'm not even causing uh
rumors there's no pizza experience be
President if he has no pizza experience
that's a great question
I think that's a platform to run on oh I
think Trump has been in the pizza
category you seen that please okay do we
have a funny story TR all these stories
are sad what about a police chief lean
on funny you don't like the police chief
dude I'm so jealous very frosted tips we
were so stupid that you doesn't like
that story let's skip I like it I
thought it was okay you're right t I
what what did you think that it's funny
well you can't I mean it's not funny but
it's like you can't you know it just
happened you got [ __ ] yeah I'm just
goofing on her hair I mean hello that's
the Internet right
you just got to own that ball master sir
but people are so stupid
her hair's not like it's not even that
crazy it's dope would you rather [ __ ]
her or mark McGrath
[Laughter]
you're right I shouldn't talk about
homosexuality and what Jesus Christ well
Jesus Christ isn't down with the homos
and I said either don't have sex with a
woman
quote is off the hinge what the door
okay so here we've got one that we'll
all enjoy ti we've spoke about because
he wanted to control his daughter's
vagina but he is trying to but he said
that he takes his daughter every year to
the gynecologist to make sure her hymens
still intact
he's and he said I'm happy and proud to
announce that she just turned 18 and up
until this moment and man's penis has
not been inside my so okay so we went on
Facebook on Will Smith's wife it's
called the red tabletop like a podcast
show on Facebook which is highly
produced by the way I yeah I was really
impressed with the quality Facebook is
really putting and them they're trying
to make real content the problem it is
that it's on Facebook
wait is that is this a rift in the Smith
house she's got a Facebook show yeah
nobody's got a YouTube show no yeah yeah
it's a pretty popular thing the red
Table Talk
but um sit on Facebook so that's the
problem it does look like TV quality
content I agree it's really well
produced I mean they are have a lot of
[ __ ] money and there's no rules
mm-hmm copyright law doesn't exist shed
hell even international law even the
Geneva Code don't even exist on Facebook
[Laughter]
here he dressed with ti Will Smith makes
a little appearance if you want to show
that in the beginning he does tea I was
like are you gonna say with us and will
is like no
I'm staying out of this one
oh that's funny I feel like this myth
family loves attention like well as a
bro yes yes he'll I don't know well just
got you know I don't know so a pillow
liner right thanks Scientology oh don't
do that family there's been rumors that
they are Scientology he donated money to
a Scientology school but so far have
denied being members of the church but I
think Will Smith is a perfect candidate
for Scientology is it confirmed that he
donated I think it's confirmed yes
doesn't that mean that he's a saint I
think what he said about that is that
they were curious about it and looking
into it and it's not it wasn't for them
I'm not sure I believe that
okay I guess I could you think I'm
famous enough to get VIP treatment with
Scientology like The Celebrity Center I
think don't care about a Hollywood I
don't know do you think they would
recognize you don't think they have a
new media division no I don't think I've
never heard of a new media I hope they
don't know yes but that's if they could
get me I hope that all the young
Scientology kids that were born into it
are managing to run away don't you think
that they have a good opportunity to
convert me like I could really get a lot
of people into it mm-hmm god they must
do how do your your Satan's feel I mean
my faden's aren't down they don't want
it they don't want it kinda it's the
ghosts that haunt you or something yes
that goes the haunt my thetans don't
believe in Scientology but I do on the
line it's good some Howdy's go so anyway
let's let's watch the Will Smith say he
doesn't want to be involved greeted and
honored properly
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and Facebook watching hey did you know
that Mark Zuckerberg sells ads to the
Russians
they don't care about democracy brought
to you by Facebook tough stuff no easy
babysit for because it's quite long may
I ask you one question
reputation why does he talk like
Yosemite Sam and you'll see what I mean
I say I say I say I do declare you'll
see what I mean well there's some of us
that know you like everything don't ya
do you understand the sensitivity of no
really I did not do you understand it no
I understand it now yes I do absolutely
however my intentions I think have been
terribly misconstrued and was conceived
let me go
see like Don King meets Yosemite Sam I
don't know all these references the guy
said it was 70 Sam yeah you sent me on
for somebody sad Yosemite Sam here's the
guy was like I do I do what is that's
foghorn leghorn bro nah this is Yosemite
Sam well I mean that is Yosemite Sam
what's the one who I was thinking of
you're talking about foghorn leghorn the
big the big chicken did I say I say oh
it's it oh that's what you're talking
about yeah I guess I thought you said me
Sam
no he's not talking like that big horn
Yosemite Sam but let's have a talk
I don't see it I like it castrate I
never said I was in any exam room that
is an assumption right that is a falsity
god I didn't think he was in the that is
a falsity who talks like that is a
falsity he goes
that is a falsity look who's talking
you're making up a word like every
second he's trying you guys know what
I'm saying he talks like he's doing a
schtick he's got he's just got a little
bit of a southern accent right okay
whatever we don't need to bait this
tensions have been terribly misconstrued
and miss constrained set this record
straight I never said I was in any exam
room that is I didn't ever think he was
in the exam room that would be horrific
I think a lot of people took it because
everyone was talking about it so maybe
you didn't say but maybe if he's in
there exam room or not it's still gross
yeah if he's an exam room that's like I
don't think the doctor would allow that
it's an assumption that is a falsity god
I never said that it was being done
present date right as it did say that
anyway I can't tell you because I
watched the whole thing basically what
he's saying is that it was kind of
obviously are they kind of trying to
make an entertaining story out of
something that is based in reality but
he was exaggerated
and I can understand that because you
know I know what it's like when we tell
stories here you try to make it a little
more funny or whatever but they do they
try to explain to him why the whole
topic is so sensitive and it really
shouldn't like why it was wrong
well he was still every year getting the
hymen examined I don't think they were
doing it every year like he was saying
in the story but he also said in the
story he told them he said as of 18
years old her hymen is still intact yeah
I think he was just like trying to be
funny you think so you don't think he's
just backpedaling no I don't what about
the tweets is done he wasn't bad it was
he was sitting there and taking in
whatever they had to say about the he
his daughter likes about saying how this
is he said that she doesn't like that
he's talking about it and he apologized
to her and should i watch its long I I
think there's like a 1 minute stretch
here he talks about 18 year old 16 years
old at the time and I never said that
her mother wasn't present right right
you know he was just you know most of
fathers don't go but he was just present
right and he didn't make the doctor's
appointment knows already you know
appointment and all of these things all
of these this narrative this false
narrative has just been sensationalized
so at the time her mother welcomed your
presence and your daughter did -
absolutely right
she did have a problem with me talking
about it I was right and I understand it
and I'm incredibly apologetic but
ultimately he was still checking his
daughters hymen so ultimately is that he
isn't the wrong and with the way he
views this whole topic and I think he
didn't understand before and he's
starting to understand now like she told
him do you know for example that it
could break from riding a horse and he
was like no I didn't know that and well
he goes in his story she ain't no Brad
no horse she do no athletics not sports
he goes
athletics because it's tik toks liking
somebody Sam I don't see it do you guys
see what is saying I don't see what do
you say knows what I'm saying I do I do
agree and do you know what I'm saying
and do you guys afraid that I'm making
like racial jokes cuz I don't think I
know I just don't think it's a cute box
like that character like he has he has a
unique cadence can we agree just a
sudden it it's not unique it's just a
southern accent he's from Atlanta I can
see why you're making this comparison
but I think it's funny when everyone
denies what you're saying yeah okay so
just hanging out to try but he agrees
Zack agrees Ian and Dan are too woke
apparently to college the obvious that
he sounds like Yosemite Sam yeah Dan and
Ella are are soon awoke and I'm calling
them out right now I'm very protective
of the Warner Brothers any of these
weirdos who you know just kind of toss
lies around for me yeah she understands
my intentions that she knows who I am
she knows who I've always been right and
I think that that allows a certain level
of understand I mean it's just the
outside the noise yeah yep it's
distracting is can is confusing it's
hurtful it is is hurtful and
embarrassing she was horrified well I
definitely understood why she would be
you know feel like you know was personal
to her right Jase is a quiet child she
doesn't talk a lot you know okay this
goes on forever I think I do I do I do I
do the class
it definitely represents like a wrong
way of looking at this things cuz he put
so much like it's so important to him
that when when she loses her virginity
and like that and he said with the right
person or whatever here's a quote from
that I pulled from 950 here so we'd have
to watch the whole thing you know from
950 let's see the idea that people
thought you were trying to control your
daughter's virginity versus now cuz
that's very different question okay ask
it okay first of all the word control is
very but you know that's what it sounds
like
no but in order to guide or direct you
must have a certain level of control of
any do you agree with that no that
doesn't make any sense
you can't guide and could direct and
control right you guide and yeah yeah
okay so okay so so how do you want us to
understand your level of control in
which you were speaking on well I think
that in the age or the time where our
women black women are the most protected
that's ten and I guess regarded yes
women on the planet yeah I'm being
criticized because I'm willing to go
above and beyond to protect my right and
I'm talking about all of the little
slimy grimy chippy fingered little boys
who want to just come in defile and
destroy the sanctity that I have I'm
saying I just find that whole yeah it's
a strength bro it's your eight-year-old
daughter what the sanctity she's got a
liver life right that's not every dude
is slimy chubby fingered sometimes you
can decide me chubby finger your vagina
on putting so much emphasis on like
losing your
exploration she's gotta do what she's
got to do I don't know you know what I
mean like yeah and if she ends up with
someone was not a good guy then she'll
figure it out for herself own you guide
her you don't say you have to break up
him because he's got chubby greasy
fingers like Newt Gingrich remember that
video yeah that's a callback
what do you call us what do you have
we'd invite now we need a new name for
these handheld device right I don't
understand anything that is the most
important thing to me in my life I am
going to deal with that with very far
reminded me of like me being a teenager
having to deal with my dad because
obviously everything he did was because
he wanted to protect me and he cared so
much about me but it was so like I
couldn't do anything
don't let me go out with my friends
wouldn't let me you know whatever
everyone else was doing I couldn't do
and it's just so frustrating it's too
you just it's not a healthy way to have
a relationship with your kid mm-hm I
understand that there's like good
intention behind it but it it's good it
don't mean anything else yeah you know I
mean for example you know when I you
know when I use the bidet to wash my
[ __ ] my tensions are good but
ultimately when there's [ __ ] water on
the floor and a whole mess cuz I don't
know it ease the bidet my intentions are
good but there's [ __ ] all over the walls
and that's why I don't step into that
right I like it and I don't understand
how that is looked at as being so wrong
in order to control for that to be
malice there must be ill intent mm-hmm
if I'm going to the stupid point hey
dude you just because you don't have to
know one cent doesn't mean that
everything you do is right and it
doesn't have a negative consequence yeah
I feel like I know exactly where it's
coming from because because of my dad
yeah
it's that old-school yeah 70 Sam should
know of controlling you but okay but if
I'm going for the purpose of being a
protective parent and there's nothing
this is overprotective there and
unprotected look one saying that's an
insane statement to make like I feel
like he doesn't even ki nobody believes
that it's true no I think it's really
there's no such thing as overprotective
when I just lock her in a jail cell
right hey baby
there's no such thing as overprotective
he treats her like she's a car and his
collection hey baby
but you in this vault with gold coins at
least he's willing to have this
conversation and they did it seem to be
like interested in learning what's
important to you though because I don't
think it's so much about virginity as
much or was it what I say I say I say I
say I say I say I say there's no such
thing as being overprotective I say
doesn't sounds like I say I say I say I
do declare to quote him one more time
all the slimy grimy chubby fingered
little boys want to just come in to file
and destroy the sanctity that I have and
anything is the most important thing in
my life I'm going to deal with that with
a very extreme care TI clearing up the
misconceptions finally we have dj khaled
trying to crowd surf imagine how this
goes you don't you can't you can't crap
you can't do that bro that's like I mean
come on dj khaled just kind of like you
just like right to the floor
people like home and we can't lift you
your Khalid it's like he lost five
pounds all like you know he's feeling
good about his way I'm glad that the
camera man's like oh [ __ ] Khalid
yeah he just thinks he just sinks that's
Khalid for you still the character still
a meme still doing it up
Rob Schneider uh I've always disliked
Rob Schneider I don't think he's funny I
think he's a douche his show sucks he he
puts a filter on his show on Netflix
called what is it called I don't have a
name for it no his show on real wrong
real rod the whole show has this
unnatural blue tint to make his blue
eyes pop more I swear to god the show
looks like a joke because everything is
so blue and the his eyes just shine so
blunt brilliant blue I'm sure that he
and post-reduction instructed them to
just put this incredible blue tint but
anyway here he is now Howie is a
notorious germaphobe OCD crippling
germophobia and Rob Schneider comes out
knowing that and [ __ ] with Howie has
returned to work this time taking on
Europe please welcome deuce Bigalow
himself Rob Schneider
you know the producers by the way or
like don't touch Howie like Harold don't
shake his hand don't touch him so the
wiseguy Rough Rider
he doesn't put his hand out he grabbed
his hand
nice to see ya
can you get over it how is have you got
to get over it I actually use that to
surgeon that I do this to I get the back
he's mine just trying to understand
right now what's going on in his head
oh look the lady's right there and the
second role has antiseptic wipes
throw it on them
[Applause]
let's talk about your life a little bit
you were recently or how I have to say
if you're that OCD though not the best
profession huh yeah host if the
producers have to be like don't touch
him don't breathe on him but Rob is
still douche and the show sucks and he's
not funny sorry also he's got the super
young Mexican wife that he the fact that
she's Mexican I don't that doesn't know
she's just exotic is what I mean South
American and in real Rob it's his real
wife she's like in her 20s and don't
think she's in her twenties let's look
it up she's actually anything a writer
on the show
oh well that's why it's no bad it's bad
I mean she's not a comedian that's what
I mean Rob what's his name Schneider
might be being a dick nobody's laughing
she's 31 so when that show came out she
was in her 20s she's 31
that show came up five years ago bro she
was like 26 I don't even know the show
existed yeah yeah you should dude you
should watch it like I'm a fan because
it's one of those shows that's so bad
I'm telling you the whole show is tinted
blue to make his eyes sparkle I'm not
kidding and so his young wife like he
has her in exercise equipment and tight
spandex doing yoga there's a scene where
you could see her ass and vag bro
because she's like she's like this and
tights workout spandex
that's crazy dude don't why you got to
watch it
am i crass why why is nobody either
looking like what's going on here yellow
what's going on here talk to me I don't
know I don't got nothing to say to me
yeah the exact is a
the show he would be Zach hold on I
enjoyed it I wouldn't say it's my
favorite show he's such a dick on the
show you like the real Rob it was
enjoyable I wouldn't say it's one of my
that I think I figured out Zach he just
likes everything I can't hold it against
and the guy likes Arby's is a car
aficionado I hated it I thought it was
so bad it was just dumb do you know what
I mean about the blue tent yeah it's so
weird he's such a dick on the show
though that's the thing he was trying to
make like a Larry David Kirby yeah
there's him except there was nothing
endearing about him it wasn't funny
he's a dick and it doesn't make any
sense like the opening scene is him let
me let me show you I'm gonna show you
this opening scene where he refuses to
tip a barista and I think let me show
you you know the reason I got into is
cuz he was on Howard and he was talking
about him promoting it so hmm
here this is the promo the sneak peek
[Music]
you claim me I'm gonna [ __ ] migrate
claim to this actually that guy guy guy
guy I'm gonna have to [ __ ] over at you
got to watch this though just for you
five bucks that's it
coffees only four bucks what kind of tip
do you expect but you're loaded you
can't afford like $100 yeah I could
afford like a thousand bucks but you're
not gonna get that either it is a cheap
bastard I'll let you bastard I tipped
100 percent actually it's 125 percent
but I'm working in a coffee shop and
you're rich you could share some of that
never happened that's my thing and by
the way the worldview that it expresses
it's all like this like Rob Schneider is
this he's this he's this rich successful
millionaire and the world just hates him
because he's so successful like the
underlying this would never happen and
it's not the dialogues not funny and he
by the way he's such a bad actor rich
you could share some of that that's how
Rob sees the world as everyone wants a
piece of them I even has like her she
kind of music he's like you could afford
more you could afford a hundred he's
like I could afford a thousand you know
what I mean damn got him so then
somebody was watching a customer was
watching yeah and the only tip five
bucks
hey you only tip this guy five bucks I
thought you were rich you made all those
movies with Adam Sandler how much I'm
supposed to tip still it made me five
bucks there's nothing to you
why would you do tip a dollar well then
you're the cheap bastard
it's like me tipping a quarter nada
tipping is all about income ratio
disparity
what you make millions right I make like
50 grand a year so $1 to me is like $100
to you where am I in Norway right now
no it's called economics where's my
economics I'm gonna go out to my 150,000
dollar car drive back to my two million
dollar house and hang out with my hot 29
year old wife planet and scene Wow I
[Music]
like it
there's $20 oh I see he's got a heart
after all work worst worst and you got
it you gotta appreciate house congratu
congratulations 1,000 I'm going to my
$200,000 car to [ __ ] my 29 year old wife
and my two million dollar house how's
that for economics how was that for
economics then do me a favor go watch
that show no it's true I'm good all
right one A two A two hot mean he loves
wrapping it up yellow wants to wrap it
up wrap it up wrap it I'll have a baby
doing it to get back to a baby we've got
a baby oh [ __ ] it's for you [ __ ] me in
the tits [ __ ] in my ass guys if you want
to leave a message it's you are you
upset no I'm actually just getting
worried about our babysitter's that
leaving at 5:00 right and now your mom
is tell my mom's there okay but have I
said something racist this episode have
I done something this way when I do
have I done something I bought a podium
for all of our body toys what if I said
something racist you guys not any more
than usual not any more than usual all
right one oh eight one eight oh eight
hot meme if you want to leave a
voicemail let's get some voicemails
going from our beautiful loving adoring
fans who are gonna go to a stress-free
shop calm and by submerge right after
this Dan my name is Reed Wilkinson up on
Kansas and you know with the decade
coming to an end I just had a couple or
just one question really about what your
guyses means of the decade all you guys
I'm curious Mima the decade I don't
really live the decade I'm not really
like so plugged into meme oh yeah this
whole thing you know what I mean with a
decade in my opinion is I'm over it
alright that's my answer
do you guys have anything that comes to
mind decades a lot [ __ ] yeah ten years
ago was like where are some of 2010
memes you remember I don't know doesn't
I don't know that's a rough one I think
it might be Ken boon oh thank you I feel
like I take credit because I'm in bone a
little bit and part of Ken's legacy you
were certainly part of the legacy yeah I
can be that's pretty that's Ken's bar
Ken bone was a greater good and Ken is
just the best I then like how it turned
into him liking preggo porn it just in
like episode it had legs
I think the humongous was a pretty
prolific name to Azhar not right
like when Bona does it have his longest
right now Penn boned was like the triple
threat yeah I mean the guy has it all
damn I just searched 2010 memes and like
dancing baby is some crazy [ __ ] man
show me what do you guys is it like rage
comics yeah a lot of rage color
yeah that's a hit she's a lot of image
macros bad bad luck Brian remember that
bro that [ __ ] ooh yeah rage comics are
single-handedly those were the worst why
you know upvote antoine dodson that
intrude should I do like that true ders
still [ __ ] funny hey I wanna know
they raping what we though wasn't such a
good one for 22 what about double
rainbows at this decade Oh double
rainbow that was right around the same
time that was like schmoyoho yeah
rainbow all the way across the sky wow
so impressed I can't believe I remember
eyes that the double rainbow all the way
across
let's catchy I think schmoyoho his name
with a decade a lot of hits a lot of
hits
Shmuel yo the my favorite one dude
before I actually was a youtuber
quote-unquote I was like the biggest
Mojo ho fan mm-hmm they were just the
coolest [ __ ] thing ever like I think
sumo yahuwah's me mother decade like
let's review his declaration chair
incredible content if I sort by popular
isn't Schmoe just Michael it's he is
Schmo yo ho but it's family it's the
brothers like Bed Intruder I wonder he
probably won't claim me for this right
this is 2010 funk you to 45 million
views
yeah and damn cuz they raping everybody
up here you know it's crazy on YouTube
these days you couldn't even this
couldn't go anywhere cuz he says rape in
the first 30 seconds and it has 145
million views we're gonna act like this
isn't one of the best videos on YouTube
like [ __ ] you YouTube double rainbow
song was I want to say that was even the
same year they were on fire think it was
this was 2010 yeah same time rainbow I
met the sky cat you to those invited me
to his cabin in Yosemite wait was he
trippin yes he was he said no he said no
but obviously
how could you react this way if you
weren't on that he said he was oh yeah I
got a fish mojo hos meme with a decade
come on
good for them just do it that was like
huge
the one there's this one of this little
kid that I want to show you guys I was
thinking I was gonna go year by year but
right off the bat in 2010 there's some
pretty solid contenders they're Sunny D
and Rahm is good
where's the one with the kid it's so
good what kid we're kid where he goes
mommy said well mommy said Oh where's
that so the parents where is that hmm oh
yeah good debate though I feel like
maybe we we should invite well the
audience to hear weigh in on this a
little bit listen that this was also
2000 was the year of memes yeah
listen LAN the song is a legit hit
[Music]
you heard him having say yeah and daddy
[Music]
I loved it
on the huge screen that is not the truth
[Music]
there's no reason that schmoyoho
shouldn't still be getting hundreds of
millions of views except the algorithm
[ __ ] them and your red table you're in
trouble
yeah I listen to this [ __ ] like a
trillion times so I give the reward
there you go I hope I answered your
question I think I did let's move on I'm
Tom and I'm from Chicago and I want to
know what happened with the mobility
scooter and did us fix it well I think
we answered that Wow Jay Simpson fan of
the show bullet ominous of a message but
I'm glad to hear that Oh Jay is a truly
thank you for calling in shoenice
oh here's someone concerned about
shooting us I just wanted to share my
concerns about you tonight I really
don't think that you guys should meet up
with him he seemed like a controller
that's what I've been saying and you
guys never take me seriously right now
I've seen a lot of videos posted by him
directed at you and the vibe that I get
from that man is not good and I
personally do not think it's a good idea
to have him on the show
well too late for that you have a
security guard I don't know are you I
would no no Scott yeah
okay now I'm searching before he comes
in I don't think it's a good idea but
wait you well you guys were laughing
when I said let's put him in a
straitjacket and put a mask like
Hannibal Lecter but I think that's
ridiculous
no but it's a good idea but you know
it's a good idea if he ever comes on the
show I'll do that that's the only way
I'll let him in this room if we put him
on a dolly we strap them to an ollie I
think it the more important step is to
blindfold him on the way to the studio
like Batcave style oh I'm sure he'll
agree to that okay take him in a hearse
oh hey this is Jen I live in
Pennsylvania and I got a question for
this podcast so every time after you
guys go to break you always come rushing
back oh wow the question we answered
that we preempted a lot of these
questions so then there's a couple more
new ones one one 808 hot meme guys
submit your questions there I'd love to
hear from you
what's on your mind you know who are you
what do you do where are you going
anyway
Orthodox did you support from Canada I
am and I'm an Orthodox Jew who's a big
fan of yours don't worry I'm not one of
the crazy altar of ultra-orthodox Jews
already I just love my religion but I
also love the means you know I've got a
foot in both worlds secular and Jewish
decide I've been watching your videos
for literally years and when he
transitioned on to the podcast I was so
happy because I'm a big fan of
podcasting I just want to let you know
you have like a whole community of fans
here in Canada that are all Orthodox
Jewish like me you know you've got
religious Jewish support I guess here in
the weird country of Canada seriously I
don't even know how to explain Canada
there's just no way to put it we're just
weird yes thanks for thanks a lot it
means keep doing keep doing what you're
doing I'm so happy Andria he's coming
back on your podcast he is my favorite
political candidate I mean I'm actually
a moderator on his discord I technically
work with the campaign it's really
[Laughter]
thanks very much I love the Orthodox
Jews I am for the call
maybe he'll be done for sure dude oh my
god all right all you all you are at the
Knux du du canada you better buy my
shirt show them everybody but I am
concerned because um you know that the
h3 fou / trooper army requires full
dedication and it sounds like these guys
he's got one foot
the meanwhile he's got one foot in the
Torah and I just think he may not have
to choose you know what I mean yeah I
mean there's only there's only space for
one cult and stay to stay - I love love
love my Orthodox Jewish fans I love them
yeah that's good but only if they see me
as a messiah if I'm just a man that I'm
not interested in right damn yeah thank
you hey Eli I am a listener from Boise
Idaho and I just want to say I'm so
proud of you for going vegetarian and
keeping up doing what you're doing
because it's great and I know you're
inspiring thousands of people out there
so keep it up at Papa black do you think
I'm inspiring thousands of people I
don't know yet
mm-hmm it's only been two weeks three
weeks you know three why are you trying
to downplay my achievements you're
always always yeah for three weeks I
gotta tell you I love it
I'm all-in I love it it's great it's a
way to win
you know I there's a phenomenon by going
on with the vegetarianism where I I'm
eating less because of the feeding
window but my dumps are like I mean I'm
not trying to be gross unprecedented
size and my brother had an interesting
theory he says cuz you're vegetarian
you're eating more volume unnecessarily
more calories more volume and I think
because I'm eating some more fiber -
it's just it's all coming out of you
which is good I good you want it out
yeah let's he get colon cancer when it's
it's seriously yeah although all the
toxins when you're eating meat and nasty
[ __ ] and burgers
yeah it sits in your colon and that's
how you that's how you get colon cancer
that's why you want to come out here
quickly who would think that you know
the colon the place where [ __ ] passes
through could you could have [ __ ] in it
too long yeah that's like saying your
garage becomes you know you can't keep
your car in your garage for too long
it'll start leaking oil man that is true
that is true you gotta move your car
every week I bet this what I've been
moving it several times a day
well that's caught that brick comes to
an end
Theodore has a very strict nighttime
routine yes you yeah so if anyone is
wondering why am I so you know wanting
to go back he starts really early with
his nighttime routine it's just the way
he wants it like we tried to push it to
later but at 5:00 that's it
he doesn't wanna play doesn't want
anything he wants his bath you know and
then after the bat it's 6:00 we give him
formula the bottle and then goes to
sleep no he's great he's got a really
cute routine he starts sleeping through
the night he's the best yeah
now you don't need that you don't need
to give a reason for it why you want to
guys 4 o'clock I mean it's like 4:15 we
got a baby a little baby update I didn't
realize it was so late was that it
that's it we did it all we said it all
we actually didn't look at the reddit
meme album we'll save that for later
we'll keep building on it we are gonna
be here on Thanksgiving Day we're gonna
shoot a special episode what no I mean
they are gonna watch this on
Thanksgiving Day you're not gonna be
here on Thanksgiving video yeah oh I
thought Friday so I guess that is Friday
put it up on Friday my bad so we will
still be coming unlike all these other
saps by the way who are on vacation not
us we got a special episode that I'm
super excited about and I don't think
you guys want to miss it so we'll be up
on Friday at the usual time no cuz usual
no everything confusing mess we're
actually gonna record it tomorrow but
our concept is very fun I think it'll be
a lot of fun so I'm looking forward to
doing that tomorrow actually it'd be fun
I'm looking forward to it a story shop
calm 1 1 808 hot meme I apologize for
all my racist remarks this show I feel
bad
know what I did but I feel Feliz making
me feel bad apologize for the minorities
[Music]
like you did
I don't ID mean I can't I don't I just
didn't understand your reference I'm
gonna have I'm gonna I know it you
thought that I was
boo booing your foghorn leghorn
comparison you thought I was saying you
were racist but I wasn't I just didn't
think he sounded like sounds like I
think he does and everybody else back
there Zach and Ian sees what I'm saying
and the Ian stayed silent just because
he likes to throw me under the bus
whenever he can and I like to return the
favor I was just afraid because you
called foghorn leghorn Yosemite that's
what I would think it over that part
okay sorry apologies to the Looney Tunes
there interventive I guess they're the
Looney Tunes I need to apologize man
look if anyone's races it's the Looney
Tunes you seen that [ __ ] how did I do
all right let's get out here thank you
guys we will see you on Friday Friday
Friday Friday so have a great
Thanksgiving and an awful Black Friday
why awful Buckeyes because they're gonna
get run over up there were fans of Teddy
freshmen or the Black Friday hands up
little tease we haven't announced it yet
and nobody's gonna hear this because
this is a deep we're gonna announce it
on Friday morning or no where's their
morning though we have a big
mother-effing thing planned for Black
Friday I'll tell you fresh you all right
let's get out of here
thank you for listening everybody you
know had to do it to him there's no
Burger backstage for me just I mean just
cut it down get about it
[Music]
you